شكرا لك ايمان معنا في هذا الموعد اللواء
فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
ولكن سنبدا معك محمود الكن وهذه العمليه
التي حدثت في مخيم المغازي نتحدث عن داخل
او تخوم المناطق التي يقوم بها
الاسرائيليون بعملياتهم العسكريه وتعتبر
بالنسبه لهم الى حد كبير مؤمنه ا نعم
بالفعل عثمان نحن اذا ما شاهدنا خريطه
المناورات العسكريه الاسرائيليه في كامل
قطاع غزه هنا سنشاهد هذا باللون الاصفر
طبعا ما نقصد به بالمناورات هو عمليات
دخول عمليات خروج حسب الطبيعه
التكتيكيه للعمليات العسكريه وامكانيه
الدخول بشكل سريع نسبيا هنا سنشاهد ان
العمليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه كانت تعتمد
على الدخول البري من الشرق باتجاه الغرب
السيطره الناريه على محور صلاح الدين في
القطاع ومن ثم الانسحاب مره اخرى لكن هذا
ايضا ما كنا يتقاطع ما شاهدناه ما شاهدناه
في المنطقه الوسطى هنا في المنطقه الوسطى
تتقاطع المعلومات ل
تشكل لتفسر ما يحدث بهذه العمليه اذا ما
شاهدنا هنا القوات الاسرائيليه كانت تحاول
التوغل من الشرق الى الغرب في طبيعه
المناورات الموجوده لكن نحن نتحدث عن
عمليه كانت حوالي 600 متر تقريبا من من
الشرق بت اجاه الغرب عاده ما تقوم القوات
الاسرائيليه بمحاولات التوغل التلغيم عمل
الحزام الناري تمهيدا للدخول وتستخدم
القوات البريه اما لكشف الانفاق او مناطق
اطلاق الصواريخ والى اخره لكن هذا ادى الى
ان القوات المدافعه قوات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه كانت قد استهدفت بعمليه مركبه
في شرق المغازي بالقرب من كيسوفيم استهداف
اول للمدرعات لدبابه ميركافا كانت ترافق
جنود المشات في هذه النقطه ايضا كان هناك
استهداف بقذائف التي بي جي او الار بي جي
الى داخل المبنى المحصن ما ادى الى تدمير
المبنى التي كانت الكتيبه الهندسيه تحاول
فيه زرع مجموعه من الالغام لتدمير المبنى
لماذا هذا التكتيك وليس الطيران ا طبعا
بعض الخبراء العسكريون كانوا يشي الى
محاوله لعمليه استهداف الانفاق وليس
فقط المبنى بذاته لكن هذا التكتيك العسكري
الاصفر عمليات المناوره نشاهد انها تتطابق
مع الانباء التي كانت خلال الفتره الاخيره
العمليه المركبه كيف تم التوغل من الشرق
باتجاه الغرب هنا وحدوث عمليه المغازي
ايضا اذا ما توجهنا الى شمال القطاع في
شمال القطاع هنا سنشاهد ك ذلك بان القوات
الاسرائيليه قامت بعمليه ايضا انسحاب او
تراجع وهذا التراجع نتحدث دوما عن تراجع
تكتيكي في هذه المناطق في شرق جباليا
اضافه الى بيت حانون العوده وتظهر خرائط
المفتوحه المصدر بانها لا توجد فيها قوات
حاليا لكن هذا دوما خلال ساعات خلال ايام
يتم التراجع
واعوده ايضا كانت هناك عمليات في غرب خان
يونس وشمال غرب وجنوب غرب خان يونس هنا
اذا ما شاهدنا هنا مركز ثقل العمليات مركز
ثقل العمليات هذا يترجم بهذه الصوره اذا
ما شاهدنا هنا هذه هي خريطه ال الالويه
الفاعله حاليا خلال او في كامل قطاع غزه
لكن بحسب المصدر وهنا نتحدث عن معهد
دراسات الحروب فان اللواء 9009 100 التابع
لفرقه 98 كان في ال من هذا الشهر لكنه في
الان من شهر يناير اصبح من ضمن الالويه
المنسحبه في هذه قراءات
كثيره لديكما عثمان واللواء فايز الدويري
شكرا محمود وسنبدا معك سياده اللواء
بالحديث عن مخيم المغازي ما حدث من وجهه
نظر خبير عسكري كيف تقراه وتوصف حدث بسبب
مهاره مقاتلي التائب القسام اهمال من
الجان الاسرائيلي كلا الامرين معا كلا
الامرين معا ولكن دعني اوضح
ذلك اذا نظرنا الى الحافه الشرقيه من
المناطق المبنيه من بيت حانون حتى نهايه
محافظه خان يونس هناك عمليه تدمير ممنهج
من اجل خلق ما يطلق عليها بافر زون من اجل
ايجاد منطقه عازله منطقه عازله تحت
السيطره الناريه على الاقل لاحقا والان
تحت سيطره القوات كما يدعوا من اجل تامين
الحمايه لمستوطنات الغلاف وفي داخل الغلاف
بداوا بانشاء سواتر ترابيه غرب الطرق
الرئيسيه لتؤمن حركه الاليات هذا يفترض
انه نموذج لما حدث في العمل هذا عملي نعم
الان ماذا الذي حدث هذه المنطقه مر عليها
اسابيع واسابيع واسابيع وهي تحت القصف
وبالتالي من وجهه نظر جيش الاحتلال اصبحت
هذه المنطقه كما يقول هو دائما تحت الصي
الان هو ينفذ بعمليه التدمير الممنهج
للمباني المشرفه والظاهره والبارزه التي
تؤمن خدمه ياتيه لرجال المقاومه فهو عاده
يعتمد على التدمير بالقصف سواء الناري
الجوي او المدفعي لكن في كثير من الحالات
تكون هناك بعض
المباني وضعها موقعها شكلها الى غير ذلك
توحي للجانب الاخر ان هذا المبنى وهو
يعاني من فشل
استخباري متاصل قد يقدم له بعض المعلومات
يستفيد منها من اجل حل لغز الصندوق الاسود
تحديدا ما اقول به هو الانفاق اذا هو يدخل
الى هذه المباني وثم بعد ان يتفحصها يتاكد
من عدم وجود اي امور بها يقوم بعمليه
التدمير فيبدو ان ه هو الحديث عن مبنيين
انا قرات في تقرير اخر ان الخطه كانت
ستشمل عشره مباني لكن هو عمليه تحضير
متسلسل وكنا نلاحظ كيف يتم تجمير مجمعات
سكنيه كامله وعرضت الفيديوهات فهو الان
يبدو ان كذلك الجانب الاخر كانه يقرا
افكاره ويعتبر ان هذا المبنى له خصوصيه من
حيث الشكل والموقع والحجم وبالتالي سيكون
ضمن اطار تفكير الجيش الاحتلال بانه سيقوم
ب تجهيزه فبدات عمليه مراقبته وتم اعداد
كمين هذا الان الكمين ثلاث يعني يغطي
ثلاثه زوايا في المرحله الا اسمح لي اطلب
مني فقط التنويه الى هذا العاجل في مستشفى
سروك الاسرائيلي استقبلنا 14 جنديا مصابا
خلال اليوم ثلاثه منهم بحاله خطيره جراء
المعارك في قطاع غزه
الان تم تفتيشه الان تمم الاعداد
لتفجيره الاعداد للتفجير من وجهه نظر
هندسيه تخصصيه بحته يحتاج الى وقت قد يكون
بالساعات اذا كان المبنى كبير اذا كان
بناؤه متين وبالتالي الان ستكون مجموعه
الهندسه هي المعنيه بنقل المتفجرات وتوضيح
المتفجرات وتوصيل المتفجرات
الجماعه اللي بتعمل في هذا المجال لن يكون
لديها ترف الوقت للمراقبه او الح حمايه او
تامين الحمايه الذاتيه لماذا هي تعمل بعمل
خطر وخطره ياتي من بعدين اما ان يحدث
انفجار نتيجه خطا وبالتالي يؤدي الى
مقتلهم او ان تفشل عمليه التفجير بسبب خطا
في تركيب الوصلات اذا هو الان هو يركز
يثبت الحشوات لديها لها طريقه فنيه اذا
يجب ان يكون له حمايه الحمايه في ظروف كذه
تكون من المشاه ومن الوحدات المدرعه
فبالتالي يبدو ان المخطط للعمليه قرا
الافكار توقع انه سينجح في مهاجمه الهدف
سينجح في مهاجمه قوه الحمايه سيكون الخطوه
الثالثه ان تاتي قوات للانقاذ والاسعاف
هذه القوات ستاتي من مكان معين حسب طبيعه
الارض فاختار هذه الارض كمنط تقتيل وزرع
بها الالغام الان نفذ العمليه على ثلاث
مراحل اطلق صاروخ الياسين دمر الدبابه
حدثت حاله من هكذا اقرا حدثت حاله من
الارباك مباشره او بعد فتره قصيره جدا تم
استهداف المبنى بقذيفه تي بي جي هذه
القذيفه تنتشر على شكل شضايا المتفجرات
الموجوده تتكون الحشو الواحده من ثلاثه
انواع حش متفجرات
عاليه وهي قويه قليله الحساسيه واسطه
الاشعال الوسطى ستكون متوسطه القوه متوس
عاليه الحسا
والاخيره تكون ضعيفه القوه عاليه لحت
الحساسيه تنفجر نتيجه اي انفجار قريب منها
الان التي بي جي ادت الى تفجير الحشوات
الان قد يطرح احد الاشخاص سؤال يوجد مبنين
ليس واحدا انا كمسؤول هندسي عندما اريد
تنفيذ هذه العمليه اشبك المبنيين في دائره
واحده سواء كاره بائيه او من خلال الك
كورتكس وبالتالي افجر بطريقتين بالطريقه
الكهربائيه وبالطريقه التقليديه حتى اذا
فشل طريقه تنجح الاخرى بعد التفجير قدمت
مجموعه الانقاذ وقعت في حقل الالغام الرقم
النهائي 21 ثلاثه في الدبابه و18 باعتبار
عادي لكن السؤال المطروح ولا
جريح كلهم ماتوا هذا غير معقول غير معقول
ير طبعا غير معقول انا اطرح سؤال استنكاري
لا يمكن ان يكونوا مات جميعا لانه القوات
موجوده في ثلاث اماكن موجوده داخل الم
اريد ان افهم اكثر ما تقوله لان الذي ماذا
حدث هل هناك اخرون مثلا وماذا حدث لهم لا
المنطق يقول القوه موزعه في ثلاثه اماكن
داخل المبنى افترض جدلا تم القضاء المبرم
عليه ماذا عن القوه المحيطه التي تعرضت
لياسين وتعرضت لشظايا التدمير في تقديرك
انت ما الذي حدث اقول ان العدد مضاعف من
حيث القتلى ومضاعف ثلاثه مرات من حيث
الجرحى ام وبالتالي انا اقول ان العدد في
مجموعه الكلي لن يقل عن 100 قتيل وجريح
والايام ستثبت
طيب ساعود اليك سيده اللواء اليوم الاصعب
اذا الكارثه الزلزال هكذا وصف مسؤولون
اسرائيليون حصيله امس الاثنين في قطاع غزه
وقد تكشف هذه الامور حجم ما حدث صباح
اليوم باعلان الجيش الاسرائيلي عن مقتل 24
من ضباطه وجنوده بينهم 21 في هجوم مخيم
المغازي كتائب القسام اكدت انها نفذت
هجوما مركبا في المخيم تضمن القضاء على
قوه اسرائيليه بتفجير مبنيين وحقل الغام
وتدمير دبابه كانت تسند القوه واكد الجيش
الاسرائيلي في تحقيق اولي اكد ان
المقاتلين الفلسطينيين ظهروا فجاه للقوات
الاسرائيليه وهاجموها وتمكنوا من
الانسحاب
اكبر عدد للجنود الاسرائيليين القتلى منذ
السابع من اكتوبر بعد 108 ايام من القتال
يسقط 21 جنديا اسرائيليا في هجوم واحد
لكتائب القسام على تصريحات المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين تعكس قوه الضربه التي تلقاها
الجيش الاسرائيلي في حربه على قطاع
غزه امس كان من اصعب الايام منذ اندلاع
الحرب لقد فقدنا 24 من خيره ابنائنا الذين
سقطوا دفاعا عن الوطن النبا الاليم الذي
تلقيناه بالامس هو بمثابه ضربه قويه هؤلاء
هم جنود الاحتياط الذين تركوا كل شيء
للدفاع عن دوله اسرائيل وحمايه الرؤيه
الصهيونيه وفق اعلان كتائب القسام فانه
عند الساعه الرابعه من عصر يوم الاثنين
الثاني والعشر من يناير الجاري في عمق 600
متر من السياج الفاصل بين غزه واسرائيل
شرق مخيم المغازي وسط القطاع كان الجنود
الاس اسرائيليون يفخخ مباني فلسطينيه ضمن
سياسه خلق منطقه عازله داخل القطاع بعد
الانتهاء من تفخيخ مبنيين استهدف مقاتلوا
القسام دبابه ميركافا بقذيفه ياسين 105
فتم
تدميرها بالتزامن مع ذلك استهدف مقاتل
القسام احد المبنيين اثناء وجود الجنود
داخلهما انفجرت القذيفه المضاده للافراد
وانفجرت معها الالغام التي وضعها الجنود
الاسرائيليون لتدمير المباني سقط المبنيان
على 21 جنديا قتلوا جميعا بقذيفه واحده
وانسحب
المنفذون يفيد تحقيق الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
المقاتلين الفلسطينيين ظهروا فجاه من بين
الحقول واقتربوا عشرات الامتار ثم تمكنوا
من الفرار لكن الاهم في هجوم القسام ان
القتلى الوا هم من قوات الاحتياط في الجيش
الاسرائيلي ينقسم الجيش الاسرائيلي الى
قوات نظاميه واخرى احتياطيه تضم القوات
النظاميه بحسب التقديرات
173000 جندي بينما تضم قوات الاحتياط اكثر
من
465000 جندي جنود الاحتياط هم جنود سابقون
انتهت مده خدمتهم الالزاميه النظاميه
فقرروا الخدمه في قوات الاحتياط عند
الحاجه اليهم هؤلاء ايد عامله في السوق
الاسرائيلي اي انهم موظفون وفنيون ومختصون
في مجال مختلفه في مؤسسات الدوله في الوضع
الطبيعي يستدعى جنود الاحتياط من 30 الى
60 يوما في السنه لابقائها في حاله
[موسيقى]
اقل فاعليه من الناحيه العسكريه الا انهم
اكثر تاثيرا في المجالات اللوجستيه للجيش
والمجالات الاقتصاديه في البلاد لذلك تعمد
قياده الجيش الاسرائيلي لابعادهم عن قوات
راس الحرب حتى لا تقع فيهم خسائر كبيره
وبالتالي يخسر اقتصاد قو عامله كان صوت
جنود الاحتياط عاليا ومسموعا في عده مفاصل
تاريخيه في اسرائيل لقد كانوا احد الاسباب
التي اقنعت الحكومه بالانسحاب من لبنان
عام 85 وكانوا احد الاسباب المهمه التي
دفعت رئيس الحكومه اسحاق رابين للذهاب نحو
اتفاق اوسلو عاقب الانتفاضه الاولى عام 93
وهم ابناء النساء الاسرائيليات التي شكلن
حركه الامهات الاربع عام 97 ومارسنا ضغطا
كبيرا على الحكومه للانسحاب من جنوب لبنان
عام 2000 تلك الخسائر في الاحتياط في هذه
المراحل التاريخيه كانت وراء قرارات
الحكومه للانسحاب من لبنان والهاء الف
فاضه الاولى بالذهاب الى اتفاق
اوسلو هكذا تكون الضربه قاسيه ويكون اليوم
ثقيلا على اسرائيل ليس على الجيش وحده بل
على صاحب القرار العسكري
والسياسي سياده اللواء ونعلم ان الذين
قتلوا حسب المعلومات الموجوده من جنود
الاحتياط ولكن سؤالي لك الان كانت هناك
خطه لتفجير مبان اخرى بعد هذه الضربه
القاصمه التي تعرض لها
الاسرائيليون في مخيم المغازي ما الذي
سييه ذلك بالنسبه لخططه في اعتقادك لتفجير
مباني اخرى بنفس الطريقه سيستمر في تفجير
المباني لكن بوتيره اقل وباجراءات
احترازيه اشد لانه هناك بعض المباني
قد توحي لهم انها ستكون مفتاح لحل لغز
الانفاق وبالتالي يجب ان يكون هناك كما
يقال اندر ريسك لكن ستكون اقل عددا وستكون
تكون الاجراءات الاحتياطيه والاحتراز اكثر
شده وسرام لتجنب ما ما جرى لكن ستستمر
عمليات التفجير طيب هناك فيديو سنشاهده
فيديو سجلته كاميرا احد الجنود
الاسرائيليين ويظهر تعرض قوات الجيش
الاسرائيلي لكمين نصبته المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في احد المباني في قطاع غزه
وكان الجيش الاسرائيلي قد نشر جزءا من هذا
الفيديو في التاسع من يناير الماضي دون
اللقطات التي يظهر فيها الاستهداف نشاهد
هذا الفيديو معا واترك الت التعليق لك س
[موسيقى]
اللواء بامكانك ان تعلق اثناء المشاهده
قتال داخل المبنى قتال داخل المبنى رغم
البعد الاحترازي له لكن مجرد ان ظهر من
فتحه الباب كان الطرف الاخر مستعد ياخذ
وضعيه الر المباشره فاصابه مباشره كان كان
رد الفعل لديها اسرع من المهاجم
نعم هذه عندما نتحدث عن
القتال من منزل الى منزل والقتال داخل هذه
المنازل فهذه كانت كاميرا مثبته على راس
احد الجنود وبالتالي كانت اللقطه واحده
وشاهدنا اصابه واحده على الاقل عند هذا
الباب هذا اثان هذا الشخص الثاني
نعم المختفي
والمتحصلات اكثر وفرصه في اقتناص الطرف
الاخر اكثر لانه يكون في وضعيه الاختباء
في وضعيه الماء بينما الداخل يكون في
وضعيه الحركه وبالتالي فرصه الثابت
المترصد اعلى من فرصه الم مع ان المهاجم
بطبيعه الحال هو الذي ياخذ المبادره وهو
هو ياخذ المبادره لكن هو الان يدخل الى
المزل وبالتالي هو يبحث يبحث عن هدف بينما
مت مترصد وهو يسيطر على هو يعرف المبل
الذي هو به وهو يعرف من اين سياتيه الخطر
يعرف انه سيدخل له من هذا الباب فيكون
سلاحه مسدد مجرد الظهور يطلق
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
النار الان تقطي لانقاذ الجريح
هم الان اولويته ان ينقذوا الجرح ان ينقذ
الجرحه نعم ولكن في النهايه اذا كان هناك
فشل في انقاذ
الجرحى بروتوكول هن بع
الموجود
يطبق يضحون بزميلهم وسبق لهم التضحيه
بثلاث جنود في في احد الافاق باستخدام
[موسيقى]
الغازات
زيروت المتحصن متخفي وجالس ولا يطلق النار
الا في اللحظه القاتله لماذا لانه اذا
اطلق النار في وقت
سيتم اصطياده لا هو يطلق طلقه واحده
ويختار مكان يختفي يراقب اي حركه يكون
جاهز لاطلاق
النار نشاهد فيديو اخر كتائب القسام ايضا
نشرت مشاهد لطائره ماتريك 600 وقالت انها
سيطرت عليها اثناء مهمه استخباراتيه لها
في شرق جباليا
البلد هذا هذا هو الفيديو الذي نشر نعم
نعم طائره صغيره
الحجم تطلق من جهاز حاسوب يسيطر عليها
تحمل 350 غرام من المتفجرات تطير لمده 15
دقيقه تتعقب الهدف وهي انتحاريه يعني هي
انتحاريه ضد الافض
تستخدم ضد الافراد ضد الافراد عندما تقول
كتائب القسم انها سيطرت عليها يعني هي
اسقطت انزلت لا هناك فرق لو اسقطت لن تكون
بحاله جيده وسليمه كما شاهدنا في الفيديو
امس كان اكثر وضوحا تم فكها وتاكد من ان
عدم وجود شرائح خاصه فيها وتم اعاده
تركيبها وقلنا تم الاستفاده منها في بعدين
البعد الاول كانت تم تفريغ المعلومات وتم
تحديد اماكن جيش الاحتلال وتم استهدافها
بالهاون والامر الاخر مؤكد انها سيتم
الاحتفاظ بها ل الاستفاد منها في برنامج
الهندسه العكسيه اذا هم استطاعوا انزالها
ل انزالها انزال يكون تقنيا ومعظم الوقت
يكون هذه الطائره طائره عوز نذكر بعض
المعلومات عنها هي طائره بدون طيار اذا
طائره موجهه صغيره الحجم ثلاث
كيلوغرامات 15 دقيقه كما تفضلت 350 غرام
متفجرات الوزن 3 كيلو كيلو صغيره الحجم
راس متفجر 350 غرام تتتبع الهدف يسيطر
عليها من جهاز الحاسوب و وكما ذكرت استخدم
لاستهداف الافراد لاستهداف الافراد
نعم بالامس شاهدت فيديو مماثل لطائره
روسيه استهدفت جندي اوكراني لكن كانت
شكلها مختلف يعني هذه تذهب الى المباني
تدخل من النافذه صغيره الحجم تدخل من
النافذه تتجول في الغرفه
يعني وبالتالي وترسل صور ليس ليس فقط في
فكره عن كيف يتم انزالها واسقاطها اسقاطها
يتم تعطيلها تقنيا ام مش استهدافها هي لا
ليس استهداف لو استهداف هذه طاره صغيره
الحجم لو اصيبت برصاصه يعني تقنيا يمكن
تعطيلها نعم كل الطائرات الد ويمكن
انزالها نعم نعم معظم الطائرات يتم يتم
انزالها خاصه الطائرات هذه التطير لمده 15
دقيقه وعلى مستويات منخفضه جدا يمكن
اسقاطها يمكن تدميرها بالاسلحه ويمكن
انزالها واسقاطها من خلال التدخل
الكترونيا بتبطيل
بابطال عملها الالكتروني الموجه لانه هذه
تتحرك باشارات من جهاز الحاسوب وب موجات
لاسلكيه
محدده وبالتالي اي عمليه جامن شامل عليها
تفقد الاتصال مع المركز وبالتالي تسقط
تتطلب مهارات تقنيه عاليه مؤكد مؤكد
واعتقد انه جماعه القسام يعني اذا انزلو
اكيد يمتلكون هذه ال يعني هؤلاء المقاتلين
قد نستغرب انه قسم لا يستهان به منهم
يحملوا شهاده الماجستير في الفيزياء وفي
الرياضيات وفي غير ذلك وبالتالي هم ليسوا
يعني كما نشاهدهم حفاف اثناء القتال لا هم
الذم المؤهلات العلميه العاليه جدا في
تخصصات نادره وتخصصات علميه
نعم اذا افاد ايضا المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان الجيش عثر على فتحات انفاق
عديده
ادت الى مسار طويل يضم مختبرا
ومخرطة هالك اكثر من شبكه كل شبكه مهد
مجهزه ل مهمه معينه
شبكات انفاق للقتال شبكه مستقله للخدمات
واللوجستيك والمنام والتصنيع كلها مستقله
لا تنفتح على بعضها بصوره واضحه وبالتالي
كافه الانفاق التي تم اكتشافها لا تعود
الى الى الانفاق المخصصه لاغراض القتال
لكن لاغراض اللوجستيك على سبيل المثال قبل
يومين عرضوا فيديو وقالوا بانه كان بعض
الرهائن متواجدين في هذا النفق و وبالتالي
لا يمكن لهذا النفق لا يمكن لهذا النفق ان
ينفتح على شبكه الانفاق القتاليه لهذا
السبب نحن نقول صندوق اسود والشفره لم تحل
بعد نعم يعني هم كانوا اصلا متحسب لهجوم
من هذا النوع من فتره طويله انا يعني ذكرت
عباره قد تكون مجازيه قلت اعتقد ان من
اشرف على اعداد المخططات الهندسيه لهذه
الانفاق لديه درجه من الذكاء قد تصل الى
المعيار العالمي 100 30 عالميه كما قلت ما
زال صندوق اسود لم تفك الشفره شكرا لك
اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي و